we are officially living in the upside
down world when i was a kid the
republicans were the party of small
government
and big corporations
the party that took the side of rich
uncle penny bags against the little guy
the party of deregulation the party most
of all of tax cuts
the democrats on the other hand were the
party of big government the party of
soaking the rich the party that assailed
big corporations
and yet today
that script
has totally flipped
just yesterday in florida republicans
passed a bill which will be signed into
law today or tomorrow
that takes power away
from disney probably the most powerful
corporation in the entire state of
florida
a bill that will raise taxes on that
corporation and re-regulate not
deregulate re-regulate its relationship
with the state of florida all because
disney opposes a law that republicans
passed that prohibits teachers from
preaching transgenderism in kindergarten
classrooms
that's another big change when i was a
kid democrats were the party that fought
the big cultural battles and won them
republicans were the losers who rolled
over today
it's the republicans going on the
offensive waging a battle to retake
cultural ground getting punched by
disney and then punching back twice as
hard
and today
it's not only the democrats but even the
operatives for open socialists who are
taking the side of the big corporations
even bernie sanders former press
secretary is shilling for a 200 billion
dollar corporation
i know
fashion corporations is popular left and
right these days i'd be careful going oh
my money
do you think those those state
legislators down in florida are going to
bend to the will of the governor did you
see what jared polis said he'd love a
rocky mountain disney
um but by the way the florida
legislature the state senate just passed
this bill to strip disney of its special
accident
i'm betting on the big corporations
honey so much for socialism
so much for the little guy
the left is putting their money on big
business against the self-rule of the
american people
it's a cynical bet
it's an immoral bet
and best of all we're seeing this more
and more each day
it's looking like a losing bet for
democrats i don't want to just get too
lost in my own ahead here i don't want
to get too far down this rabbit hole of
the realignment that we've heard so much
about in recent years that the the
republicans or the party of the people
now and democrats have become the party
of the rich i don't want to just be in
my own echo chamber
which so often we are so i have brought
on one of the most aggressive one of the
most progressive people that i know
coincidentally the host of the
aggressive progressive podcast you've
seen him on lots of television stations
fox news in particular and all sorts of
places
chris hahn chris first thank you for
coming on the show
hey how you been man you're looking thin
well thank you very much i i've really
tried to style myself a um what's the
word uh skinny i don't know i've tried
to style myself as sort of skinny that's
just me being jealous man that's just
leaving a jealous but i wish i had your
hair i wish i was as thin as you stop it
you're gonna make me blush i
i need a reality check or maybe not
maybe you agree with my take on this
are the
are the party you know we hear so much
in the 1960s that the parties switched
and republicans usually argue against us
are the parties switching now are the
republicans speaking more toward regular
ordinary
mainstream blue-collar issues and are
the democrats showing for the
corporations um no i think uh you know
even if you look at this bill that they
just passed in florida it gives them a
year to kind of work out the details and
i have a feeling in that year
uh ron desantis will be off in iowa
running for governor and the people in
florida are going to say yeah no we
don't want to piss off the biggest
employer in the state of florida uh how
can we work this out they also don't
want to take on disney's debt
which they would have to do if they
reintegrate disney into that surrounding
area there's some other bonding issues
it's not just the you know uh zoning and
other things they talk about in this
bill there's some bonding issues that
assumingly the people of the state of
florida would have to take on if this
bill actually goes to effect which will
be a year from now based on what's
actually in the legislation
so yeah no i don't think that that will
actually happen and when i hear people
like simone sanders talking about
um you know i'm betting on the
corporation she's right because they're
gonna get their way here as they almost
always do especially in that state with
that particular corporation quite
frankly i don't want anything to to
threaten uh my ability to enjoy the ben
kenobi series that will be coming out
very shortly on disney plus i'm really
looking forward to that uh so uh you
know let's hope i don't have to pay an
extra dollar a month because of ron
desantis attacks on disney um so you
know i i think ultimately that will
happen as for the don't say gay bill uh
as an aggressive progressive i am happy
to see that democrats have adopted a
tactic that republicans have long used
take an early draft of the law and then
paint the entire law and everybody who
supports it as that for example yeah the
green new deal uh the you know the
republicans found got a hold of a
brainstorming memo from some staffers
about maybe banning meat and that was
what the green i think you and i were
debating it at one point that was what
the green new deal became in the eyes of
most americans but chris you've got at
least a grand deal now you've got to at
least grant republicans went after the
green new deal that maybe they went
after an early draft maybe they've
changed their mind the democrats have
changed their mind about some parts of
it but but it was always called the
green new deal it was to bring back this
idea of fdr's major overhaul of the
economy whereas in florida
whatever you think of the parental
rights and education bill it doesn't ban
the use of the word gay it's it's great
that the democrats have adopted this
tactic and branded the bill don't say
you're saying it's politically great
hold on hold on acknowledge the skill
there yeah right it hasn't it hasn't
been the democrats it's not has been not
been their strong point or at least
people other than me it has not been the
strong point of the national party to
take something and say remember when
they said that you weren't even let them
say this in class and they branded the
bill that and now they painted it with a
brush it's going to be very hard you
know not this year look this is a good
year for republicans
um if this was if this was two years
from now i don't know that ron desantis
would be attacking this hard white he
only won by half a percentage point four
years ago but it's a great year for to
be a republican he's got a hundred
million dollars in the bank the
democrats have a messy primary going on
down there probably gonna uh you know
have charlie crist as their as their
nominee and i don't know where that goes
okay uh so so even the environment he's
in he's you know he's using it to his
advantage so you're saying that this is
an interesting point that i actually
haven't heard a lot of people say you're
saying that on the the
d the first bill that we're talking
about that the disney
take away their self-governance bill
that's going to raise their taxes you're
saying it's actually kind of cynical i
don't think it's really going to go into
effect it's just a way to get a lot of
headlines but ultimately disney's going
to win okay so but it never could go
wrong by calling a political uh attack
cynical it's completely cynical and
that's why it's not taking effect
tomorrow but then okay so let's say
let's say i even grant you the premise
then right then let on the point of the
don't say gay bill let's say i even
grant your premise that okay it's not a
totally honest slogan to use for the
bill but it's a good tactic and it's
going to be effective but then what do
you make of this chris 60 of americans
broadly support the parental rights and
education bill the majority not only of
florida republicans but of florida
democrats support the parental rights
and education bill so don't you don't
you have to say but but 70 of americans
oppose the don't say gay bill remember
frank luntz i mean this is the kind of
thing that people you know yeah you call
the parental rights and education bill
people are going to support it you call
it the don't say gay bill politically
it's toxic but i guess you're so i grant
you that point on on the names but when
there there have been polls actually we
conducted one of the polls that when you
take away all the names you don't even
name the bill you just focus on the text
of the bill people support the
provisions
absolutely just like the affordable care
act when you call it you you know people
support almost everything in it unless
you call it obamacare and then they
don't but the affordable care act won
ultimately it did win so i guess what
i'm just asking is isn't this isn't
opposition to this bill even if the
democrats have been smart about the
sloganeering or whatever isn't it
ultimately a loser for democrats to be
on the side of of teaching
transgenderism in the classroom and on
the side of a big corporation that is
not what's happening here what's
happening in this bill even now even in
the bill that passed
it makes it illegal
for a kid to talk about their weekend
with their two parents that might be of
the same gender well it only it only
prohibits teachers from saying things
well how would the teacher then react
when one of the kids in the class say
what does it mean that he has two
mommies i mean you said go ask your
parents
well
mike
let's be clear
um the arc
this is you're not gonna win the
argument long term attacking
uh same-sex couples attacking
homosexuals it's not going to happen but
do you think they're going to win
in america this this battle has been won
and while there might be a moment right
now based on the political environment
for him to attack further the right to
bolster his base so that he might do
well in iowa
i i mean it it's so cynical it's so bad
then let me okay a little people who
shouldn't be let me put the question
another way you you've advised democrat
candidates you're obvious your head is
in this all the time so you're sitting
there with democrat presidential
candidates this issue is going to come
up the issue of disney pushing
woke sexual ideologies and specifically
the issue of teachers in kindergarten
through third grade class this is the
thing we keep he keeps going out he's
calling it woke ideology disney
supported their gay employees and there
are many of them who were offended by
this bill sure and as a result as a
result
ron desantis is attacking disney but
will ultimately cost the people of
florida money because now they're going
to have to police disney they're going
to have to assume they're bond debt i'll
go i'll go with all
i'll go with a parade of horribles but
by the way i'm telling you right now
i'll put money on this invite me back
this time next year
this bill will never go into well okay
listen
you might be you might be right before i
let you go we're over as usual but it's
but i need to i need to ask
last time i saw it i was in tennessee i
was getting hot chicken we were debating
with a national legend i know we somehow
we ended up in a three-person debate the
recording articles that came out before
your mother was born when i was at
clinton my father's eye
but i have to i have to ask you this
question so let's say i grant everything
you're saying about the bill it's not
going to go into effect it's this that
and the other thing
if you're advising a democrat candidate
today do you tell them democratic
candidate you went to yale use proper
english kids if you are advising one of
those crazy about that maniacal and why
you didn't use the yes and method to
kind of rebut that question but maybe
we'll do that another time do
if you're advising one of these
candidates do you tell them
lean into the florida
education bill defend kindergarten
teachers talking about this stuff or do
you tell them this this is this year the
year of our lord 2022 do you tell them
lay off the bill it's a political nation
say gay bill and lean into it that
scores well and lean into it don't let
them call it the parental rights and
education act or whatever you know like
because that is a different look again
language matters frank luntz is a genius
he's an evil genius but he's a genius in
the way he you know the death tax oh my
god the death tax you're gonna tax me i
made a hundred thousand dollars in my
lifetime and they're gonna take it away
from my kids no it was about people
making over 10 million dollars a year
getting a gradual increase and he called
the debt crisis
with the bite inflation pretty soon your
100 grand is gonna be on paper ten
million dollars so we'll have to deal
with
predictions here i we are going to have
you back many times we're going to
figure out you look you might be right i
don't know we're keeping an open mind uh
chris where can people find you uh at
christopher hahn on twitter christopher
hahn ny on instagram although nobody
cares about me on instagram i'm another
old one i follow all that i'm always
looking for your story updates i have i
have lots of pictures of my dogs on
instagram and christopherhan.com all
right go find chris thank you so much
for coming on
you like that clip cool ring the bell
get those notifications head on over to
apple podcast spotify stutter google
play subscribe to the michael knowles
show podcast leave a five star review
we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]